es hat in den letzten tagen ja immer
wieder warnungen vor solchen anschlägen
gegeben und dass das nun eingetreten ist
es natürlich eine bedrückende nachricht
wir kennen noch nicht alle einzelheiten
aber die terroristen haben auf menschen
gezielt die vor den flughafen toren
gewartet haben und auf ihre ausreise
hoffen sie wollen sicherheit und
freiheit für sich und deshalb ist dies
ein absolut niederträchtiger anschlag in
einem nach sehr sehr angespannten
situationen und ich denke in diesen
minuten natürlich an die opfer und ihre
angehörigen ich hoffe dass die nötige
medizinische hilfe schnell gegeben
werden kann und
mit den nationen die dort ihre
bürgerinnen und bürger und bedrohte
afghanische bürger in sicherheit bringen
zusammenarbeiten wir sehen also an
diesen ereignissen des heutigen
nachmittags dass das risiko immens ist
und das ist eine sehr sehr große
drucksituation ist mit der menschen
außer landes gebracht werden und die
luftbrücke arbeiten kann wir wissen dass
das zeitfenster sich schließt und es
konnten zehntausende menschen in
sicherheit gebracht werden aber ich will
heute noch einmal bekräftigen diejenigen
die mit der luftbrücke nicht mehr in
sicherheit gebracht werden können werden
wir nicht vergessen sondern wir werden
uns weiter um ihre ausreise bemühen dazu
finden ja auch gespräche seitens des
auswärtigen amtes insbesondere auch von
einem patzer mit den taliban statt und
es wird auch international koordiniert
werden wie wir weiter vorgehen
ich möchte jetzt zu unseren beratungen
sagen dass wir uns ausgetauscht haben
über die ökonomische lage
weltweit hier sind die experten
versammelt und wir sehen das im verlaufe
der pandemie
die erholung mit zwei geschwindigkeiten
stattfindet und dass es natürlich eine
nachricht die uns umtreibt wie können
wir auch gerade den
ländern selbst mittleren einkommens und
den entwicklungsländern gute
perspektiven der wirtschaftlichen
erholung geben und deshalb sind eine
reihe von internationalen maßnahmen
sowohl durch die g 7 als auch im bereich
der des iwf und der weltbank in angriff
genommen worden hierzu gehören
schuldenmoratorium hierzu gehören die
sonderziehungsrechte die wir jetzt so
verteilen müssen dass die ärmsten länder
der welt davon etwas haben und ihre
wirtschaftlichen schwierigkeiten
überwinden können wir haben sehr
intensiv uns eben über die situation des
impfens
besprochen das werden wir beim
abendessen auch noch vor zu suchen denn
rein so fangen sollen der
wirtschaftlichen kanzlerin zu den
anschlägen vom flughafen in kabul es
sind mindestens 13 tote mindestens 70
verletzte das wissen wir bislang bei mir
im studio jetzt unser politik chef jan
schäfer jan wie ordnet du die äußerungen
der bundeskanzlerin ein also haben
gesehen angela merkel war gerade durch
ausgezeichnet von den vorkommnissen die
sie jetzt gerade eben noch mal
beschrieben hat am flughafen von kabul
man muss ja fast sagen das war ein
abschiedsgruß der terroristen also
letzte bundeswehr maschine ist heute aus
kabul gestartet ein makaberer
abschiedsgruß und die bundeskanzlerin
hat sich gestern in ihrer
regierungserklärung auch gesagt wir sind
gescheitert eigentlich mit unserem
einsatz den wir da 20 jahren afghanistan
hatten du hast angela merkel häufig auf
pressekonferenzen erlebt wenn sie solche
statements abgegeben hat hast du schon
den eindruck dass sie diese geschehnisse
ganz besonders bewegen auch ja wegen der
kritik an ihrer politik der kritik an
dem abzug also das war sicherlich jetzt
eine pressekonferenz wie man sie auch
nicht alle tage sieht angela merkel ist
sonst eher nüchtern auf
pressekonferenzen wir erinnern uns an
die zahlreichen erklärungen nachdem
corona gipfel da ist sie nicht gut
gelaunt aber da wirkte sie doch jetzt
gerade eben sehr gezeichnet wir uns auch
an den auftritt im kino beispielsweise
wo sie ein herzhaft gelacht hat man das
war jetzt schon eine angela merkel der
man anmerkt dass das ganze an ihr nagt
dass sie auch merkt da waren
möglicherweise viele entscheidungen die
die bundesregierung getroffen hat oder
eben auch nicht getroffen hat nicht
richtig dass warnungen in die luft
geschlagen wurden also ich glaube angela
merkel merkt das schon dass vieles von
dem was ihre regierung getan oder eben
auch nicht getan hat jetzt zu dieser
situation mit beigetragen hat jan
schäfer vielen dank für die einordnung
das war also unsere breaking news zum
statement von bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel nach den zwei schrecklichen
selbstmordattentaten die dort am
flughafen von kabul stattgefunden haben
wenn es neuigkeiten gibt aus kabul
erfahren sie das selbstverständlich
weiter hierbei bild live wir
unterbrechen dann unsere sendung zur
champions league auslosung
[Musik]